[Applause]
now uh folks if you could just uh
indulge me for a second i'm having a
problem i wanted to talk to andy about
uh andy i i don't mean to bring this up
in the middle of the show but i'm having
kind of a moral dilemma
and i need your help okay uh i um
earlier today i found this
i found this ring downstairs in the
lobby
and i'm not really a ring person at all
i don't like rings that much but
i'm looking at it it's a really really
nice ring
and actually when i put it on i think i
think it makes me look really elegant
and uh i do i just think it's it's cool
and
you know yeah i mean it's a it's a very
nice ring
um looks good on you but i don't
understand why it's a problem
well any the problem is i just don't
know whether i should keep the ring
or whether i should return it to the nbc
lost and found because maybe someone's
looking for it and i really love the
ring and i'm just
well i'm torn i'm really torn that's
that's something you're gonna have to
answer for yourself i can't
i can't tell you what to do yeah you're
uh
you're right andy but uh i i just
don't know what to do
[Applause]
keep the ring conan rings look great on
your fingers
i'm sure the owner will never miss it
conan keep the ring conan and
keep the ring
yeah that's all true that's those are
those are really good points but
um you know i just can't help thinking
there's another side to this issue
[Applause]
hello i am your bear
[Applause]
andy it's the bear again the bear again
yeah
bear where's the angel i don't know
but i do know that thou shall not
scratch your back
against a pine tree for the sap will
make you all
[ __ ]
um don't listen to the bear conan
the bear is wrong keep the ring it's
really you keep the ring
yeah yeah bear would you just get to the
part about the ring
please all right we're talking about the
ring um
remember always maul people with your
front paws
your back paws are just to keep you from
tipping over
you know i'm sorry no comprende elbeiro
yeah look bear you're really confusing
everyone would you just give me
some good advice here come on you can do
it um
never mate during bear hunting season
better to be horny than dead
well congratulations bear you just made
the devil look good all right
would you just please say one thing
about the ring
what's a ring sorry i'm late fellas i
was on the can
hey who are you
no oh god oh my god that humanity please
ladies and gentlemen ladies and
gentlemen this is the worst thing that's
ever happened on my shoulders during a
show
we're going to take a break we'll be
right back with frederic i'm sorry
you